Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. Henry Cavill and the Warhammer
People have been talking
about the upcoming movies and series
that they're working on, so we'll break it all down.
Henry Cavill has been pretty quiet
about his new Warhammer series until recently.
and it was actually Games workshop.
The people who make the Warhammer Games,
who actually hold the rights to it,
who he's been waiting on, it turns out.
And they just made a bunch of big announcements
about everything, what's going on.
Basically, If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Of course, I'll do episodes for this new Warhammer
series when it starts and whatever.
Warhammer movies Henry Cavill winds up making
because he does talk about making a Warhammer
cinematic universe.
that just means there'll be both TV series and movies.
It just sounds like he's starting with a TV series.
it's been about a year to the day
almost since Henry CAVILL'S last big Warhammer
post that he made publicly announcing
that he was making the new series of the new movies.
This is what he actually said about that For 30 years,
I've dreamt of seeing a Warhammer
universe in live action.
Like I said, he's been a fanboy of Warhammer
playing the game for the past 30 years
now, after 22 years of experience
as an actor inside Hollywood, I finally feel
I have the skill set and experience
to guide a Warhammer cinematic universe into life.
Like I said, Cinematic universe, meaning movies
and TV shows, partnering with Natalie exclusively.
So at Vertigo has been a blessing beyond words,
probably because Vertigo holds the rights to the TV
shows in the movies without her,
we might not have found the perfect home at Amazon,
meaning that the TV show will drop on Amazon
it will give us the freedom to be true
to the massive scope of Warhammer,
just meaning that Amazon is going to let them
do whatever they want to do with the Warhammer
series, the Warhammer movies
To all you Warhammer fans out there,
I promise to respect this IP we love.
I promise to bring you something familiar
and I endeavor to bring you something fantastic
that is as of yet unseen,
meaning that they haven't actually made it yet, like
they're still trying to get it going.
Our first steps are to find our filmmaker
creator, writer.
Watch this space, my friends, for the Emperor.
Games, Workshop and Amazon
separately made some announcements that also explained
why things have been so quiet during 2023
when we actually going to get episodes,
when is he going to start filming?
What's the timeline on these Warhammer episodes?
when are we actually going to see the movies?
When are they going to come out?
what characters are they going to focus on?
Like which part of the Warhammer universe, which
character is Henry Cavill going to play in all this?
apparently when Henry Cavill
made his initial announcement Games workshop,
the people who hold the rights to Warhammer,
they make all the physical games.
They get to sign off on all the video games,
the other Warhammer stuff produced by other people.
They announced that they'd finalized their deal
with Amazon to get basically
all the rights to do any movie story,
any TV series story set
anywhere in the Warhammer universe
during any time period with any of the characters.
whereas before,
when Henry Cavill was making his initial announcement,
the rights were apparently still kind of a mess
all over the place with a bunch of different people
Previously there have been other people
who had tried to make a Warhammer TV show.
there was one in 2019, the Games Workshop announced,
but it wasn't
part of Henry Cavill's deal,
like Henry Cavill didn't have anything to do with it.
Amazon didn't have anything to do with it,
and they haven't said anything about it since then.
now Amazon apparently has all the proper rights
for everything Warhammer related.
In Henry CAVILL'S Warhammer
series and movies can move forward.
Finally, in any other Warhammer stuff
that Amazon might want to do, even though it does sound
like Henry Cavill's projects are the first Warhammer
things that they'll be focusing on.
if you have no idea what's going on.
Henry Cavill is a lifelong Warhammer fan boy.
That's why in his initial post he talks about it
so specifically, like it's so personal to him.
if you've never seen him talk about it in real life
or listen to any of his interviews,
even when he was still playing Superman
in the DC Justice League movies, when he was doing
The Witcher,
he would talk nonstop about his love of Warhammer.
He literally interrupted a Warhammer
Netflix promo interview
to geek out on Warhammer with Joey Batey,
who is also a huge Warhammer fan in real life.
Henry, let's start with you.
Specifically.
Which universe or just I mean, just sound like in guys
so many I've got now, ruling out the which.
Yeah, no, I mean, the easy answer is Warhammer 40,000.
That is my, my jam.
I have been into it since I was ten.
What's your army at the moment?
Custodes. Yeah, I'm going.
I'm going to Macron's next tweet. Okay.
All right, cool.
Were you. Yes. Were you into this before or.
yeah.
Let's just assume that anything nerdy
I've been doing for a good thing.
wow. We could talk for hours.
Yeah, So, yeah, this is that.
That's. That's my jam.
And that's the stuff
I do. My free time. That's amazing.
Amazing. I'd love to see your.
Your arms, your collect. Do you paint them yourself?
Yes. That's so cool. Yeah. Is it?
Thanks. When
googling something,
I painting, like I say, is really enjoying the future.
I think. I think I'd be surprised.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I think This is what you need to do and your trailers
on the off time during season three, you paint many
Face painting time. Yeah.
if he didn't realize Warhammer is mostly viewed
as being a hardcore UK thing now, obviously
it's international all over the place,
but it has a much richer history inside the UK
Recently Games Workshop
just confirmed all the stuff that Henry
Cavill had been talking about
and he's continuing to work on those projects.
It sounds like legally
he wasn't allowed to actually start
working on the like pen to paper
until all these deals were finally made.
no surprise that lawyers always ruin all the fun
They released a video
of Henry Cavill visiting their studio
a while ago, like a couple of years ago.
That was probably when Henry Cavill had started to work
with them on their side of things,
like, Yes, I would love to make a Warhammer
series in Warhammer movies.
Let's make that happen. Like,
how do we make that happen?
the funny thing about this, you see him geeking out
about all these figures, all these setups here.
He does this in real life, like when you just catch him
in his free time, he's just sitting there
painting his little Warhammer figures.
one of the biggest traditions of the Warhammer
fandom is actually model creation.
when he talks about creating his models,
that's what he means.
the initial announcement about all this
last year was timed right as he was leaving
the Witcher Netflix after season
three like it was right as Season
three was getting wrapped up in
after he left the Superman role at DC.
Others more of a chance to return
as an older Superman in the future.
Pretty sure, though,
we will not see him back on The Witcher since
that's supposed to end after Season five.
Now with Liam Hemsworth
having taken over with the recasting.
there have been a lot of stories
about why he left the Witcher, Netflix,
why he's not the main Superman anymore.
But there's more details on all the Superman.
DC stuff just because all that was way more public
and way more reported on.
part of the reason why he left
The Witcher was because he didn't really
have any creative input on the show,
like he was just an actor for hire.
He was a huge Witcher geek for the original books
and the games.
in it sounds like just because the Netflix Witcher
series wound up making so many big changes
to the original story,
he didn't really agree with everything in
wanted to work on his own projects that he originated
that he would have creative control over,
and it was just taking them forever
to make all these Witcher seasons.
So which is dragging on and on and on, burning daylight
when he could be working on other projects
that he did have control over.
then along comes
the opportunity to do a Warhammer series and movies.
And he's been a Warhammer
geek way longer than he's been into The Witcher
or even into the DC Superman lore.
so just seems like a no brainer
for him to leave The Witcher.
The reason why he left
Superman is a little more complicated, less by choice,
because he would have totally continued.
They were originally planning
on making Man of Steel too.
They had much bigger plans for him
in other future DC movies.
That's why he released this video
after his Post-Credits scene, The Black Adam
movie came out I wanted to wait
until the weekend was over before posting this
because I wanted to give you all a chance
to watch Black Adam.
But now that plenty of you have.
I wanted to make it official
that I am back as Superman.
And the image you see on this post
and what you saw in Black Adam,
are just a very small taste of things to come.
So there's a lot to be
thankful for, and I'll get to that in time.
But I want to thank you guys.
Most of all, thank you for your support
and thank you for your patience.
I promise it will be rewarded.
literally, just like a couple of weeks after that,
maybe even less than that, they announced that James
Gunn had been hired to be the new Kevin Fire DC,
essentially with his producing partner
and they were going to reboot the DC
Universe in their plan was completely different,
recasting all the Justice League actors.
so really does feel like Warner
Brothers was jerking around
Henry Cavill for a long time,
trying to keep him on the hook for playing Superman,
like teasing him with the idea that he could come back
as Superman, then bringing him back.
Then immediately taking that all back the way he talks
about it publicly, though, he took it all in stride.
Like he took it like a gentleman.
Like,
okay, like, obviously you have very different plans.
He could always come back as Superman.
I think he was trying to leave the door
open like he doesn't want to burn too many bridges.
Like he could have it out with him in public.
But I do think that personally, he is a true gentleman.
That is just the way
that he acts personally in privately.
So it's not like he hates James Gunn
or he hates Warner Brothers or anything like that.
there's no bad blood between them and James Gunn does
like Henry Cavill and did enjoy his role as Superman.
I've done a couple other videos about all the craziness
that happened at Warner Brothers
the last couple of years.
Like there were a couple of buyouts
that did not work out for them.
they went up hiring David Zaslav,
the guy that's been canceling everything.
Like you probably been seeing memes about him
all over social media for the past couple of years.
there's like a whole saga behind the scenes
before they hired James Gunn
to reboot the DC movies into Superman legacy
and all the new stuff that they're announcing.
But essentially the effect is to leave
Henry Cavill free to pursue any movies in any TV shows
that he wants.
Like he doesn't have to worry about being on the hook
for a bunch of other big franchise movies
at the moment, Amazon is basically going to let him do
whatever he wants.
That's kind of their deal.
and because he's such a stickler
and such a fanboy for accuracy to the Warhammer lore,
the Games workshop, people on their side of things
love him and will probably let him do
whatever he wants to do pretty much a lot of people now
wondering who is he going to play like?
Is he going to do an origin story
for the emperor of mankind?
Like before he just winds up sitting in the chair
absorbing all that psychic energy from everywhere
are a lot of characters from the universe.
That universe that I want to be.
But I can only really be one because once I'm one,
then I can't be others.
Five years You'd make a very good Google Horizon.
Don't I think that I mean, that would be exciting. Yes.
But then I burn, fry marks and and the Captain general.
It is obviously character rich,
especially the shared universe.
I suppose I could play a different character
from the Warhammer fancy
universe versus
the 40 K universe, he's got a bunch of options.
So let me know who you want Henry Cavill
to play what you want the story to actually focus on.
I'll do more Warhammer videos
when he reveals more details.
It'll probably be a little while.
I'll try to do videos this week for Zack Snyder's
Rebel Moon, Netflix Movie two and four Aquaman 2
My What if Season 2 episodes
will also be starting in a couple of days
make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
Click here to learn why Marvel just fired
Jonathan Majors as their Kang
the Conqueror and click here for that
Justice League Crisis on Infinite Earths trailer.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!